okay okay we're back okay here are the
questions Larry as someone who grew up
in Trump village you grew up in Trump
village grew up in Chumphon wait there's
such a thing as Trump village yeah it's
a Soviet housing complex and yes built
by his father taking advantage of the
the New York housing laws at the time so
do you have any memories of the younger
Trump that you can share he said we had
a Little League field that was built and
he came with his father to christen the
Little League and he was still like in
exactly the same shapeless suit and the
weird here even at 14 and so I he was a
kid when he was a kid he and he was
wearing a suit he was Trump jr. yeah he
was very he was like the guy he is now
only like the mini-me version of it he
grew into the full the full of do you
know thing little individual Wow yes
okay everyone how should the u.s. best
deal with Venezuela but we have to
support the opposition I think we need
to I think the president is right to
divert the money to what we have
declared is the legitimate government
you know the current the the outgoing
government so Maduro is not legitimate
and then you know come up with real
assistance work with the international
community as always this administration
doesn't do enough diplomatically to keep
this issue and others front and center
okay here shed
how do you how do you recommend people
stand up for what they believe while
also avoiding the behavior that you
criticize in your book as I said earlier
right we live in this hyperpolarized
time and so often we throw labels at one
another and then roll our eyes and walk
away which changes nobody's mind rather
we should be actually starting
conversations where none would have
existed before especially with people
who disagree with us for one thing you
can actually glean information from the
other person that helps you reframe your
argument in a way they can understand
last week at the end of the show I
mentioned you in my editorial because it
was about how Democrats should go on Fox
News which they don't they're invited
they just don't go he goes yeah you're
the one only one who goes that was
Friday night I pick up the paper the
next day and it says Donna Brazile good
for her has joined Fox News and she said
exactly the same thing I was saying the
night before that you know you gotta go
where the people are and you got to talk
to people who don't agree with you and
it's again it's another sorry to say it
it's another way the Democrats look weak
talk to people who don't agree with you
but also don't discount how many I've
seen this yeah where people come up to
me and say I love watching on Fox News
especially women and they'll say I'm not
a Republican but my husband makes me
watch it that's all that's on the TV
station or the bartenders who have that
in their bars because the owner wants it
why would we want to dismiss the husband
makes me watch a human right
that's hear that a lot but yeah I have
lots of people cover conservatives often
come up to me I watch your show I don't
agree with everything you say but you
have conservatives on and sometimes you
express a point of view I agree with and
you know and funny you know funny makes
up for a lot of respect for and they
respect you for it what do you think
congressman of Devon Nunez is a lawsuit
against Twitter parody account oh my one
against the cow I mean they got their
snowflakes on the right - boy did they
have snow that cow has more followers
than he does now right the cow has more
follow couldn't he see that coming if he
if he announced the lawsuit that it was
just gonna create that yeah the good
news is we took the gavel out of his
hand
right yes you should focus on other
things
[Laughter]
I'm gonna chew on that all weekend
fake Moo's I mean we cope some of us
that you know if justice really is done
some people will be going to jail right
up until the person of the number one
what about these people like Devon Nunez
who were just incredible enablers
Lindsey Graham people like that what
what is what is the appropriate
punishment for them when this is all
over
former congressman also obstructing this
as much as they possibly could we go
further than just voting them out of
office buried the evidence we saw that
for two years but you know what let's
just make him a former congressman all
right definitely not what they would say
yeah dangerous precedent that can be
used against anybody all right Kristin
do you think Republicans will be willing
to take action on anything incriminating
that may appear in the mullet report
that's what are you high or will they
continue to protect Trump no matter what
but what I can say and we sort of
mentioned this on the show is why is it
that Republicans have been so loath to
criticize Trump that when behind the
scenes behind closed doors they'll sort
of grumble about him I wish she would
stop the tweet so I don't know like this
thing you did or that thing he did and I
think part of the reason why you see so
few Republicans say putting out press
releases saying we think that what the
president said about John McCain is
important is I think there is a sense
that it is futile to do so that the
Democrats are already on it and that if
they do so all it does is make them an
enemy of the president meaning that the
policy stuff they like is harder to get
done and if they're not actually
changing any minds and those Republican
voters who I talked to in those focus
groups it's only once they realize that
they're inside the family that they're
like I wish you would stop the tweeting
it's so annoying but they feel like if
you're somewhat like someone
Paul Ryan who I am sure you think did
not do nearly enough to criticize
President Trump when I go into these
focus groups they think Paul Ryan was
traitors to the president for daring to
have put out a couple of press releases
from time to time saying he shouldn't
have said what he said at
Charlottesville and so they're these a
lot of these Republican lawmakers I
think feel at a total impasse that if
they put out that press release they put
out that condemnation they're not
changing who Trump is fundamentally as a
person he's still gonna say crazy stuff
he's still gonna insult people their
press release isn't changing that so
they just don't put it out and it makes
them look weak I agree but that's that's
whipped they're stuck between and why
you hear crickets when Trump does some
of these what do you think they're gonna
win
2020 well last time you asked me to
predict I thought Hillary Clinton is
going to connect yeah we have that clip
I mean I think Trump will be very
formidable his approval ratings not
great but it's not terrible it's above
40 percent which is historically bad
place for it to be but for Trump it's
not the worst it's been and I think it
depends who did Democrats nominate do
they do they listen to you bill do they
nominate someone who isn't gonna turn
off all of those voters in the middle
who don't love the tweets who don't love
everything Trump does but do the
Democrats nominate someone that they can
potentially get I don't even know who
that is
he's not gonna be President in 2021 I
promise that I've talked to the
Republicans you've talked to you if
their position we'll wait a second
there's no we really want to be
complacent like that and don't worry
bullets in the bag no no we're gonna
beat them and I have the confidence we
did in Michigan what we get in
Pennsylvania will begin the Wisconsin
but no I wouldn't address what you said
about my Republic not the right message
why we may not beat him no I think it's
the rice that you've talked about
because if they just believed in what
Donald Trump was doing and that's why
they can't speak out against him I would
give them that but what they tell me
privately is I'm afraid that if I speak
up he tweets he was and what bothers me
is that I would like to think that as
members of Congress they're otherwise
employable that this isn't the only job
that they could get that they actually
could do the right thing feel good about
it and that's what's so maddening
because all tweets are not equal and the
ones where he espouses or excuses
violence or where he speaks out against
and calls the media the enemy of the
people all those things that actually
get or or criticizes the Justice
Department the police what have you what
you name it those tweets go run counter
to democracy they're attacking democracy
yeah if Republicans can't stand up and
say something then we're in real danger
because the democracies die book says
you can prevent democracy if the two
sides can come together based on
principles like defending our
institutions well
I've been saying for over two years he's
not gonna leave even if he loses I think
you're on my quiz with that right yeah
absolutely I agree that's what I'm
afraid about 2020 as you're saying and
what happens then it's like a getting a
tick out of your it's about the feeding
trumpism and not just Trump well let's
start with all right last question are
Trump's feuds with George Conway and the
late John McCain well that one's
different but worthy of the media's
attention I don't think that his feud
with George Conway is and I don't feel
comfortable sort of even speculated I
mean a lot of this is involved like
speculation about their marriage and I
think that's really unseemly and it's
also in a way kind of like the Devin
Nunez Cal thing it's like a Streisand
effect the most people are not following
George Conway on Twitter and so it
elevates this when the president Lee the
president tweets about in every news
network goes oh the president tweeted so
now it's news and we can talk about it
how could I marriage like that every get
back yeah I mean after a week like this
I know how much you're ever going to get
back I mean it's it's a big problem
but how would though either they have no
sex or the hottest hate sex right one of
the two all right thank you everybody
[Applause]
you